This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. All right, turning on to South Temple Road. Road, place? It's just called South Temple. South Temple is in fact the complete name of the street on which our producer Sam Greenspan is driving. Crossing 500 East. Exactly 660 feet later Sam drives across the next major street. Here's 400 East. And 660 feet after that. 300 East.
这里是 99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。好了，转到南圣殿路。路，地方？它就叫南圣殿。事实上，南圣殿就是我们的制片人山姆·格林斯潘正在开车的这条街道的完整名称。穿过东500街。整整660英尺后，山姆开车穿过了下一条主要街道。这是东400街。此后660英尺。东300街。
If you recognize the streets that Sam is calling off, you already know exactly where he is. And what he's about to say. 200 East. And now here's State Street, which seems to work like a 100 East. Wow, there it is. Oh my gosh, that is the Mormon temple.
如果你认得出山姆正在念出的这些街道，你就已经确切知道他在哪里了。以及他接下来要说的话。东200街。现在这里是州街，它的作用似乎就像东100街。哇，就是它。噢天哪，那就是摩门圣殿。
The Salt Lake Temple of the Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day Saints in Salt Lake City, Utah. It's quite striking. It's beautiful. The urban grid of Salt Lake City, Utah, is designed to tell you exactly where you are in relation to Temple Square, one of the holiest sites for Mormons. I first learned about this when I was writing a letter to a friend in Salt Lake, whose address was like 300-something south, 2100-east Salt Lake City UT, which to me sounded less
位于犹他州盐湖城的耶稣基督后期圣徒教会的盐湖城圣殿。它相当引人注目。它很美。犹他州盐湖城的城市网格旨在告诉你，相对于圣殿广场这个摩门教最神圣的地点之一，你确切身处何地。我第一次了解到这一点，是我在给盐湖城的一个朋友写信时，那个朋友的地址类似于盐湖城南300号左右、东2100号，这在我听来与其说是一个具体的门牌号
like a specific house number and more like a set of coordinates. But that's pretty much how every address works in Salt Lake City, and in Utah generally. 300-south, 2100-east means South, and 21 blocks, East of Temple Square. But the most striking thing about Salt Lake's grid to us non-utons is the scale. Each block is 660 feet on each side. That means you're walking more than two football fields to get from one intersection to the next. Salt Lake's blocks are the biggest in the country. You can fit nine Portland Oregon blocks inside one of Salt Lake cities.
不如说是一组坐标。但盐湖城以及整个犹他州的几乎每个地址都是这样运作的。南300号、东2100号意味着位于圣殿广场以南、以东21个街区。但对于我们这些非犹他州人来说，盐湖城网格最引人注目的是它的规模。每个街区每边长660英尺。这意味着你要走两个多足球场的距离才能从一个十字路口走到下一个十字路口。盐湖城的街区是全国最大的。你可以在盐湖城的一个街区里塞下九个俄勒冈州波特兰市的街区。
These giant blocks have created some challenges for the city of Salt Lake, but they were all part of the original plan for the city. One created by its Mormon founders a century and a half ago in an effort to create a spiritual utopia in the desert. Every city plan begins as someone's utopia. Urban planners imagine the way their city ought to be, make some drawings, and then watch as that vision becomes reality.
这些巨大的街区给盐湖城带来了一些挑战，但它们都是该市最初规划的一部分。这个规划是由其摩门教创始人一个半世纪前提出的，旨在沙漠中创建一个精神乌托邦。每一个城市规划都始于某人的乌托邦。城市规划者想象着他们的城市应该有的样子，画一些图纸，然后看着这个愿景变成现实。
Throughout most of human civilization, urban planners imagine their cities arising from a system of streets joining at right angles. A grid. The idea of a grid goes back at least to 2600 BC in the Indus Valley in what is now Pakistan and Northwest India. We know this from archaeological findings. Ancient Egypt had grids, ancient Babylonia had grids, the Greeks and the Romans had grids. Many cities in Europe don't have a grid, but when European settlers came to North America,
在整个人类文明的大部分时间里，城市规划者想象他们的城市从成直角交汇的街道系统中拔地而起。一个网格。网格的概念至少可以追溯到公元前2600年的印度河流域，即现在的巴基斯坦和印度西北部。我们从考古发现中得知这一点。古埃及有网格，古巴比伦有网格，希腊人和罗马人也有网格。欧洲的许多城市没有网格，但当欧洲定居者来到北美时，
they mostly built grid-iron cities. When Joseph Smith found her of the church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day Saints, the religion of the Mormons, first conceived of a holy city for his new religion, he would not have had much experience with large, urban grids. He was born in New England, and then when he was young,
他们大多建造了棋盘状的城市。当耶稣基督后期圣徒教会（摩门教）的创始人约瑟·斯密第一次为他的新宗教构想一座圣城时，他可能没有太多关于大型城市网格的经验。他在新英格兰出生，年轻时，
his family lived to upstate New York. He never would have saw a city that had more than a couple thousand residents. This is Dr. Benjamin Park. My name is Benjamin Park. I'm an assistant professor of American religious history at Sam Houston State University. Dr. Park says that Joseph Smith's foray into urban planning began with a document called the plat of Zion. The plat of Zion was a map that details all the way down to how big the housing plots would be, how many roads would fit into this city, where the courthouse would be, where the temples will be, how many people will live within these boundaries. It's a plan which
他的家人搬到了纽约州北部。他绝对没见过居民超过几千人的城市。这是本杰明·帕克博士。我的名字叫本杰明·帕克。我是萨姆休斯顿州立大学美国宗教史助理教授。帕克博士说，约瑟·斯密对城市规划的涉足始于一份名为《锡安之图》的文件。《锡安之图》是一张地图，详细说明了房屋地块的大小、这座城市能容纳多少条道路、法院在哪里、圣殿在哪里、这些边界内将居住多少人。这是一个规划，
Mormons believe came to their prophet Joseph Smith, part in parcel with a series of revelations that led him to found the Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day Saints, a plan which would inspire the Mormons eventual spiritual home in the Salt Lake Valley. Have you been in the temple square before? Yeah, I was here yesterday. I was walking around.
摩门教徒相信这是他们的先知约瑟·斯密通过一系列启示获得的，这些启示引导他创立了耶稣基督后期圣徒教会，这个规划将激发摩门教徒最终在盐湖谷的精神家园。你以前去过圣殿广场吗？对，我昨天来过。我在周围散步。
I got to see some of the sights. So we don't have to point out which is the tabernacle, which is the temple. Feel free to. Thanks, good radio. Showing Sam around Temple Square is Keith Erickson, director of the LDS Church History Library. Accompanying them is Emily Ut,
我看到了一些景点。所以我们不用指出哪个是会堂，哪个是圣殿了。请便。谢谢，好广播。带山姆参观圣殿广场的是LDS教会历史图书馆馆长基思·埃里克森。陪同他们的还有LDS教会的历史遗址馆长
historic sites curator for the LDS Church. Say I could go on for about three weeks about Temple Square. Keith and Emily took Sam to the LDS Church History Museum. So we'll just kind of through the exhibit and find it. The planet itself is over here. So this is it. This is the original.
艾米丽·乌特。我说我可以讲大约三个星期关于圣殿广场的事情。基思和艾米丽带着山姆去了LDS教会历史博物馆。所以我们只需穿过展览并找到它。规划本身就在这里。所以就是这个。这就是原本的。
This is what they described and named the Platt of Zion. The three of us are gathered around a display case in the museum that's actually pretty easy to just walk right past. I actually think the display case here understates the significance of what's in it. It's just a rough-hune, you know, it's designed to look like a rough-hune wood box. Inside, under thick museum glass, is a large piece of parchment with Joseph Smith's urban plan for an American city of God. The temple blocks in the middle are kind of this ochre, kind of red color, and
这就是他们所描述并命名的《锡安之图》。我们三个人聚集在博物馆的一个展柜周围，这个展柜其实很容易直接走过错过。我实际上认为这里的展柜低估了其中内容的意义。它只是一块粗凿的，你知道的，它被设计成看起来像一个粗凿的木箱。在厚厚的博物馆玻璃里面，是一大张羊皮纸，上面有约瑟·斯密为美国上帝之城制定的城市规划。中间的圣殿街区是这种赭石色、有点红色的颜色，而
the streets are labeled in a kind of a light green. The document we're all looking at, the plat of Zion, is a city plan, a series of squares divided up by horizontal and vertical lines. It is one of the first documents that the Mormon prophet Joseph Smith and his scribes produced. It's a pretty simple system, very large blocks, 660 feet on each side, all forming right angles with one another. All of them the same, except for these special blocks in the middle, which he imagined would hold 24 temples. The city's grid was designed so that you would always know exactly how far you were from
街道则用一种浅绿色标出。我们都在看的这份文件，《锡安之图》，是一个城市规划，是一系列被水平线和垂直线分割开的方块。它是摩门教先知约瑟·斯密和他的抄写员制作的第一批文件之一。这是一个相当简单的系统，非常大的街区，每边660英尺，彼此都形成直角。它们都一样，除了中间这些特殊的街区，他设想那里将容纳24座圣殿。这座城市的网格设计成这样，以便你总是能确切知道自己距离
its spiritual center. I see these definitely as divinely inspired. These are coming from a man who had never seen a big city, who would probably never heard of city planning, and was really looking at this as the basis of a revelation to understand how the kingdom of God looks when it hits the earth. This zionic city that Joseph Smith imagined would be as big as New York or Philadelphia or Boston War at the time. It would be an attempt to harness the best things a city could offer, infrastructure,
它的精神中心有多远。我绝对认为这些是神圣启示的产物。这些来自一个从未见过大城市的人，他可能从未听说过城市规划，并且真的将此作为理解当上帝的王国降临地球时是什么样子的启示基础。约瑟·斯密想象中的这座锡安之城将和当时的纽约、费城或波士顿一样大。这将是一次尝试，旨在利用城市能提供的最好东西：基础设施、
education, community, but without the less savory bits like vice and crime. Joseph Smith sought to achieve this by giving people lots of space. It would effectively be a rural city. Within the large blocks, each church member would have a plot of land to have fruit trees and vegetable gardens. And Joseph Smith imagined the essential piece of the urban fabric would be the home. Again, Dr. Benjamin Park. I think he would have rejected the general separation of commercial and domestic living.
教育、社区，但没有那些不太体面的部分，比如恶习和犯罪。约瑟·斯密试图通过给人们充足的空间来达到这一点。它实际上将是一个乡村城市。在这些大街区内，每个教会成员都将拥有一块土地来种植果树和蔬菜园。约瑟·斯密设想城市结构的基本要素将是家。再次有请本杰明·帕克博士。我认为他会拒绝商业生活和家庭生活的普遍分离。
You would go to a shop that's based out of someone's homes. But Smith never got to experience his mixed use, walkable, everything artismally crafted utopian community. After leading his converts to Ohio and then Missouri and then Illinois and clashing violently with locals pretty much everywhere they went, Joseph Smith was killed by an angry anti-mormon mob in 1844. The leadership of the LDS church fell to a member of Smith's inner circle, a man named Brigham Young. Brigham Young leads a large number of the church out west to what was then Mexican territory.
你会去一家以某人家为基地的店铺。但斯密从未能体验到他那混合用途、适合步行、一切皆手工打造的乌托邦社区。在带领他的信徒前往俄亥俄州，然后是密苏里州，再到伊利诺伊州，并且几乎在他们去过的每个地方都与当地人发生暴力冲突之后，约瑟·斯密于1844年被一群愤怒的反摩门教暴徒杀害。LDS教会的领导权落入斯密核心圈子的一名成员手中，一个名叫杨百翰的人。杨百翰带领教会的大量成员向西前往当时的墨西哥领土。
After a journey spanning years, the Mormons entered the Salt Lake Valley in 1847 and established Salt Lake City. It would be the first place that they could build exactly as they wanted. And when Brigham Young began devising a plan for what they would build, he returned to Joseph Smith's Platt of Zion. Brigham Young's plan does look a bit like Joseph Smith's Platt of Zion, but with more detail and some changes. I see this utopian idea of hitting some problems
经过多年的漫长旅程，摩门教徒于1847年进入盐湖谷并建立了盐湖城。这将是他们能够完全按照自己的意愿进行建设的第一个地方。当杨百翰开始为他们将要建造的东西制定计划时，他又回到了约瑟·斯密的《锡安之图》。杨百翰的规划看起来确实有点像约瑟·斯密的《锡安之图》，但有更多的细节和一些改动。我看到这种乌托邦式的想法在
when you have to start dealing with actual landscape. That's Emily Ut again with the LDS Church. Brigham Young realized quickly that the plate of Zion wouldn't work in the real world without some modifications. Smith's plan called for 24 temples at the center of the city. Young decided to start with one. Brigham Young also realized that the city couldn't survive on cottage industries alone. They would also need some commercial and industrial districts.
你必须开始处理实际景观时遇到了一些问题。再次是LDS教会的艾米丽·乌特。杨百翰很快意识到，《锡安之图》若不经一些修改，在现实世界中是行不通的。斯密的计划要求在城市中心建造24座圣殿。杨百翰决定从一座开始。杨百翰还意识到，这座城市仅靠家庭手工业是无法生存的。他们还需要一些商业和工业区。
There were limits to the rural city idea, and the mountainous terrain of the Salt Lake Valley didn't lend itself to a regular rigid grid. But in many ways, Brigham Young's plan for Salt Lake City is faithful to the plot of Sion. The city is still, after all, built around a temple square, and with streets named in a way that tell you exactly how far you are from it at all times. And the orderliness of the grid dovetails with Mormon sensibilities about the spiritual importance of maintaining a tidy home. Brigham Young and his fellow Mormons did not stop with Salt Lake City. Over the next half century, they built about 700 towns based on a similar plan, all over
乡村城市的想法有其局限性，盐湖谷多山的地形并不适合规则、死板的网格。但在许多方面，杨百翰对盐湖城的规划忠实于《锡安之图》。毕竟，这座城市仍然围绕着一个圣殿广场建造，街道的命名方式可以随时准确地告诉你你距离它有多远。网格的井然有序与摩门教徒对保持整洁家庭的精神重要性的感悟相契合。杨百翰和他的摩门教同伴并没有止步于盐湖城。在接下来的半个世纪里，他们根据类似的规划建造了大约700个城镇，遍布
Utah. And in many of these towns, they kept Joseph Smith's prescription for large city blocks, 660 feet on each side, with wide streets between them. The joke is you could turn a wagon around in the middle of the block. Actually, one version of the joke I heard is that the streets are wide enough to be able to turn a wagon around without the driver's resorting to cursing. Knowing Mormons, that's probably very true. In Salt Lake City, the wide streets and huge blocks have the effect of making you feel kind of small.
犹他州。在其中许多城镇中，他们保留了约瑟·斯密对大城市街区的规定，每边660英尺，街区之间有宽阔的街道。开玩笑的说法是，你可以在街区中间调转一辆马车。事实上，我听过的一个笑话版本是，街道足够宽，可以让司机不用爆粗口就能调转马车。了解摩门教徒的话，这可能非常真实。在盐湖城，宽阔的街道和巨大的街区会产生一种让你觉得自己有点渺小的效果。
And they say that everything is bigger in Texas. I just don't think those people have been to Utah before. This is Molly O'Neill Robinson, urban designer for the Salt Lake City government. We're walking around downtown Salt Lake and she's showing me just how hostile these wide streets can feel to pedestrians. We are crossing the street right now.
他们说德克萨斯州什么都大。我只是觉得那些人以前没去过犹他州。这是莫莉·奥尼尔·罗宾逊，盐湖城政府的城市设计师。我们正在盐湖城市中心漫步，她正在向我展示这些宽阔的街道对行人来说会让人觉得多么充满敌意。我们现在正在过马路。
We're crossing fourth South, also known as 400 South. So we were given 27 seconds to cross a 132 foot right of way. The blinking pedestrian sign gives us less than half a minute to cross six lanes of traffic. We're walking in a normal pace, not enough time to cross. Many, if not most streets in Salt Lake City, even streets in the heart of downtown, are four or six lanes wide, all because the plat of Zion called for streets with a width of
我们正在穿过第四南街，也被称为东400南街。所以我们只有27秒的时间穿过一个132英尺宽的路权。闪烁的行人信号灯给我们的时间不到半分钟，让我们穿过六车道的交通。我们以正常的步伐行走，根本没有足够的时间穿过。盐湖城的许多街道，如果不是大多数的话，甚至是市中心核心区的街道，都有四到六个车道宽，这全是因为《锡安之图》要求街道宽度达到
a 132 feet. Back in the day, things were platted and measured using the surveyors chain. Surveys chain is 66 feet, also known as one furlong. The width of our street is two furlongs, which is 132 feet. The streets are so menacing
132英尺。过去，人们使用测量链来规划和测量事物。测量链是66英尺，也被称为一弗隆。我们街道的宽度是两个弗隆，也就是132英尺。这些街道
to cross that the city tried making them safer by offering pedestrians bright orange flags. The basic of a lamp post, there is a bucket affixed to it, kind of like a plastic. And there's like one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight. Uh, at least, they're pretty big. You're supposed to pick up a flag and carry the flag with you as you cross the street for added visibility. Should we do it?
太难横穿了，以至于该市试图通过向行人提供亮橙色旗帜来让它们变得更安全。在路灯杆的底部，有一个固定在上面的桶，有点像塑料的。这里大约有一、二、三、四、五、六、七、八。呃，至少，它们挺大的。你应该拿起一面旗帜，在过马路时随身携带这面旗帜，以增加能见度。我们该这样做吗？
Um, we should. And I'm. Should we do it? We should. And I'm going to make you do it because... You're embarrassed? No. I refuse to carry a flag. All right, so we're crossing now. I am waving this flag. I've seen these crossing flags in other places.
嗯，我们应该。而且我。我们该这样做吗？我们应该。我要让你这么做，因为……你觉得尴尬吗？不。我拒绝拿旗帜。好吧，所以我们现在在过马路。我正在挥舞这面旗帜。我在其他地方见过这些过马路旗帜。
My neighborhood actually has them at the intersections near the elementary school. But it does seem kind of absurd to ask people to carry bright orange flags in the downtown of a large American city. We made it across and I'm going to drop this in the bucket. So you refuse to carry these. So I refuse to carry the flag on principle, and that I believe that our streets should be designed to inherently make pedestrian crossing safe. And if you have to carry a flag across the street to get someone to notice you, then we haven't designed the street safely. And difficulty crossing the street is not the only
我的街区在小学附近的十字路口实际上也有这种旗帜。但在一个美国大城市的市中心要求人们携带亮橙色旗帜确实显得有点荒谬。我们过来了，我要把这个放进桶里。所以你拒绝拿这些。所以我原则上拒绝拿这面旗帜，而且我相信我们的街道本应被设计成天生就能确保行人过马路的安全。如果你必须带着旗帜过马路才能引起别人的注意，那么我们就没有把街道设计得安全。而且过马路困难并不是
problem with large blocks. Urban planners have long known that short blocks are inherently more interesting because there's a greater density of what they call network nodes or sites of possible interaction between people. Shorter blocks mean more intersections, and more intersections mean more options for what to do or where to go. Given the problems at large blocks and wide streets have created in Salt Lake, you might get the idea that Salt Lake's founders
大街区唯一的缺点。城市规划者早就知道，短街区天生更有趣，因为他们所称的网络节点或人与人之间可能互动的地点的密度更高。较短的街区意味着更多的十字路口，更多的十字路口意味着你可以做的事情或要去的地方有更多的选择。鉴于大街区和宽阔的街道在盐湖城造成的问题，你可能会产生这样一种想法，即盐湖城的创始人
just started out with a bad plan. Not at all. Oh no, what you're seeing there is a complete misunderstanding of bringing a's conception. That's Andres Duani, a partner with the architecture firm DPZ. He's also one of the founders of the new urbanist movement, which seeks to make cities and suburbs less car-oriented, more walkable, and more environmentally friendly. Andres Duani says that in Brigham Young's original
一开始就制定了一个糟糕的计划。完全不是。噢不，你在那里看到的完全是对布里姆构想的误解。那是安德烈斯·杜阿尼，建筑事务所DPZ的合伙人。他也是新都市主义运动的创始人之一，该运动旨在使城市和郊区减少以汽车为导向，变得更适合步行且更加环保。安德烈斯·杜阿尼说，在杨百翰最初的
plan, the streets were never supposed to be paved from curb to curb. The streets were basically a green space, with pavement only in the parts where settlers wanted the ox carts to go. And Brigham Young never imagined that the huge blocks originally meant for farming would remain intact as the city evolved. He understood that the blocks would have to be subdivided from agricultural to urban over time. For Duane, the Salt Lake City we have today represents the stagnation of Brigham Young's dream. So Salt Lake City went from the most beautiful to actually the most hostile in the West.
规划中，街道从未被打算从路缘铺到路缘。街道基本上是一片绿地，只有在定居者希望牛车通过的地方才有路面。杨百翰从未想过，最初用于农业的巨大街区会在城市演变过程中保持原样。他明白，随着时间的推移，这些街区必须从农业用地细分为城市用地。对杜阿尼来说，我们今天看到的盐湖城代表了杨百翰梦想的停滞。所以盐湖城从最美丽的城市变成了西部实际上最具敌意的城市。
And that's a misunderstanding of the intention of Brigham Young and the plat of Zion. Making the city less hostile to pedestrians is exactly what anti-orange flag Molly O'Neal Robinson is trying to do. She wants to take those huge blocks, break them down into more walkable sections and make them more interesting. You know, that there's something kind of engaging and delighting your eyes, you're moving along.
那是对杨百翰和《锡安之图》意图的误解。让这座城市对行人不那么充满敌意，正是反对橙色旗帜的莫莉·奥尼尔·罗宾逊正在努力做的事情。她想把那些巨大的街区拆分成更适合步行的部分，让它们更有趣。你知道的，当你前行时，总有一些吸引人并取悦你眼睛的东西。
Molly is hoping to do this block by block in Salt Lake City. She took Sam to one current project on Regent Street, where they're working on getting more pedestrian life into the middle of the block. So Regent Street is really the first pedestrian first street in Salt Lake. So the street has always been here, but you're kind of redesigning its use? Yes, yes. Regent Street used to just be an access road for some downtown parking structures. Now, it's a pedestrian walkway that opens up into a plaza with a brand new feeder,
莫莉希望在盐湖城逐个街区地做到这一点。她带着山姆来到了摄政街的一个当前项目，他们正在那里努力将更多行人生活引入街区中间。所以摄政街真的是盐湖城第一条以行人为主的街道。所以这条街一直都在这里，但你们在重新设计它的用途？是的，是的。摄政街过去只是市中心一些停车场的通道。现在，它成了一个行人步道，通向一个带有全新餐饮、
a new restaurant space. The idea with this street is that we will be able to close down portions of the street for festivals and events, big theater openings, things like that. As of the time of this recording, Regent Street is still under construction. But even so, people are already drawn to walk through it. The stakes for creating a denser, more walkable salt lake are high. Even though the city feels wide open and nature is easily
新餐厅空间的广场。这条街的想法是，我们将能够在节日和活动、大型剧院开幕等期间关闭部分街道。截至本录音时，摄政街仍在建设中。即便如此，人们已经被吸引着穿行其中。打造一个更密集、更适合步行的盐湖城的利害关系很高。尽管这座城市感觉开阔且很容易亲近
accessible, Salt Lake suffers from some of the worst air pollution in the country. The mountain ranges around the city, trapped in all the smog, which largely comes from cars. With more, Salt Lake is expected to double in population by 2050, and it can't expand its city limits because of geographic boundaries, like mountains, and a great, big, salty lake. The city's ability to thrive will be determined by its ability to make more efficient use of the space it already has. There's a lot of optimism in the city for finding better ways to use its large blocks
大自然，但盐湖城遭受着全国最严重的空气污染。城市周围的山脉锁住了所有的雾霾，这些雾霾很大程度上来自汽车。随着更多人口的涌入，盐湖城的人口预计到2050年将翻一番，而且由于地理边界（如山脉和一个又大又咸的咸水湖），它无法扩展城市边界。这座城市蓬勃发展的能力将取决于其对现有空间进行更有效利用的能力。该市对于寻找更好地利用其大街区
in wide streets, and there's been some progress. But several developers told me that the new city administration has not been kind to these approaches. They seem to be more about keeping Salt Lake City as it is. In the Church of Letterday Saints, there's a principle called continuous revelation that God is still speaking, and that divine truths are still being revealed. And so maybe what Salt Lake City needs, maybe what all American cities need, is a kind of continuous revelation, a way of honoring the need, is a kind of continuous revelation,
和宽阔街道的方法抱有很大的乐观态度，并且取得了一些进展。但几位开发商告诉我，新的市政府对这些方法并不友好。他们似乎更倾向于让盐湖城保持原样。在后期圣徒教会中，有一个原则叫持续启示，即上帝仍在说话，神圣的真理仍在被启示。所以也许盐湖城所需要的，也许所有美国城市所需要的，是一种持续启示，一种尊重
a way of honoring the principles on which a city was founded, but with the understanding that they must adapt and respond to the demands of the present. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Sam Greenspan, which refutes of Katie Mingle Kurt Colstead, Avery Truffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Morris. Special thanks to James Alfondre, Thomas Carter, Reed Ewing, Sam Warwick, Jason Brown, Catherine Daly, and Kurt Radke. All the songs and remixes on this episode were made by the great Ok Akumi on the great Hell Audio label from the great state of Utah. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco,
城市创立所依据的原则的方式，但要理解它们必须适应并回应现实的需求。本周的99%隐形由山姆·格林斯潘制作，凯蒂·明格尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、艾弗里·特拉夫曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德兰妮·霍尔、泰兰·马扎以及我罗曼·莫尔斯协助。特别感谢詹姆斯·阿尔方德雷、托马斯·卡特、里德·尤因、山姆·沃里克、杰森·布朗、凯瑟琳·戴利和库尔特·拉德克。本集中的所有歌曲和混音均由来自伟大犹他州的伟大奥克·阿库米在伟大的地狱音频厂牌下制作。我们是旧金山91.7KALW的项目，
introduced on Radio Row. beautiful downtown Oakland California. You can find this show in joint discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI orc. But you can find all things 99% invisible at 99pi.org. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在无线电街区推出。美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与关于该程序的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（@RomanMars）或@该节目（@99PIorg）。但你可以在99pi.org上找到关于99%隐形的一切。